this quintessentially Mediterranean
landscape blend centuries of artistic
and architectural accomplishments with
one of nature's perfect panoramas the
breathtaking terrain includes dramatic
coastline topography scattered with
vineyards orchards and pastures often
with enchanting views of the vibrant
waters below kind climate abundant
resources and natural beauty have drawn
people to this coast for many centuries
and the Greeks Romans Normans Saracens
Arab Sicilians and many others have left
their mark pounds like Amalfi and
Ravello are home to many examples of
artistic and architectural excellence in
past oome column temples to Poseidon
Hera
and Athena are among the best preserved
of their kind to be found anywhere in
the world until the 1800s the steep
terrain of the coast meant that overland
access to the region was possible only
by mule while many oases of quiet can
still be found here particularly away
from tourist centres the Amalfi Coast
has changed irreversibly since then
[Music]